- The thing
(upbeat ambient music)
that has kept me in a very strong position
from the earliest wine videos I made
to what I'm gonna do tomorrow
is I have never talked about
something I don't know, ever.
First of all, it's a real pleasure.
I think content creation
and all of you are in it
so a lot of this stuff will make sense,
but I think the first thing
that I think about always
is self awareness.
I think the biggest issue
for content creators
is them being inspired by someone else,
and then them subconsciously,
not even consciously,
subconsciously trying
to be like that person,
which is an incredibly difficult task
because every one of us
in this room, me included,
have strength and weaknesses
in their ability to create content.
So I think there's a couple
things to think about,
one, your own self-awareness
of what you're good at.
For example, I'll give you one,
I think the concept of writing content
is like forgotten in a visual world,
yet, I can tell you
that some of my written
content on LinkedIn
is dramatically more profound
and does well than my clips
on TikTok or Instagram.
And there may be people in this room
whose strongest method of communication
is actually in written form,
yet, the push towards
short form video or images
make them work on that
when they're deviating from a strength.
So I think first and foremost
what I think about is a couple things
and they're all in the
form of transparency
and self-awareness,
one, what are you best at communicating?
Is it audio, video, written form?
Two, the thing that has kept
me in a very strong position
from the earliest wine videos I made
to what I'm gonna do tomorrow
is I have never talked about
something I don't know, ever.
I think when you're a content creator,
you feel pressured to output.
And when you feel pressured to output,
you can get very caught to start talking
or creating around something
you may not fully understand.
A lot of people come and go
and there's some very clear
truths to having success.
And I think it's one,
understanding your format,
while still trying to challenge yourself.
You may be better at writing,
it's still good to try
to be better at video,
but it's not crippling yourself
and thinking you can only be
successful if you do video.
Two, do not deviate from your knowledge.
Now that doesn't mean
going, like look at me,
I'm talking about NFTs.
I spent a 100 hours of research
before I made my first video,
but putting in the work
to be able to talk about
something new is very important.
The quickest way I've seen people lose
is by being too quick to talk
about things they don't know.
Very important.
Number three,
a very big thing for everybody
to keep in mind here,
do not fall in love with the
platform that got you there.
A very big thing that
I've seen consistently
in the last 15 years
is Twitter was your strong
platform, here came Instagram,
and you didn't want
Instagram to become big
because you didn't wanna start over
and build up your following count.
So many, and this is gonna
make sense for all of you,
so many leaders on Instagram
made a huge mistake
by not adopting TikTok, right?
They didn't want to 'cause
they had all their followers,
constant mistake being too
romantic about platform
and not adjusting to where the
attention is actually going.
Those are some themes that I
would give a lot of thought to.
- I think one of the
things we focus a lot on
is writing as well.
So we're trying to teach teams
that really scripting out
to storytell before they create content.
So that definitely goes in
line with what you said.
Platforms a little bit more.
How do you manage that?
I mean, it's a lot of work
to be on six platforms.
Especially when you are starting out.
How do you recommend they do this?
- You know, the way you do it
is a couple different ways,
one, I think that a lot of people get hurt
by the ideology of perfection.
So I think one of the reasons
long before I had DRock
or a team, I was able to by
myself while running businesses,
be active on every platform
is because I didn't ideologically
think about every single piece of content.
I think when you're
trying to make every piece
perfect for yourself,
perfection is usually just
another word for insecurity.
You know, everyone's overthinking it.
And so one, it's to feel
comfortable with that,
number two, is to be okay with
not being on six platforms.
You know, I think sometimes
we feel too much pressure
to be everywhere,
I talk about it, like be
everywhere, post a lot.
A lot of people can't
manage that and that's okay.
I believe it has to do
with insecurity of success
of the piece of content.
The biggest reason people
didn't go to TikTok
when they were winning on Instagram
was they didn't have the
humility and the self confidence
to not be successful
on TikTok immediately.
So I think the biggest
reason people don't produce
is more of a mental game than,
it's not hard to produce
content for six platforms.
It's really not.
You can do it.
It's that people fear
lack of success in numbers
from a vanity standpoint,
which stopped them from actually doing it.
So I think humility, humility
is one of the true superpowers
of a scaled influencer or content creator,
being okay with starting at zero
or being okay if the
content's not doing great.
Super.
- I'll give you another,
I mean, for example with me on TikTok,
even though I know it's the
most important platform,
I don't have the time to
produce original TikToks,
so I know my post produced content
doesn't maximize my
ability to win on TikTok,
but I'd rather still put out stuff
and get what I can
than be insecure
that I'm only getting
50,000 views on a TikTok
when I have 13 million followers,
that doesn't register to me as a negative,
for too many people it does
register as a negative.
- There's still a lot of people over here
that are reluctant to move into TikTok.
We still have that around here.
Is that the case globally than?
- It's the case globally.
It's a huge mistake.
TikTok is eating up the attention
of the consumer by the second,
to be a content creator,
like to be in this room
and to not be producing content for TikTok
is virtually unacceptable.
I mean, if you're a content producer,
that's just a,
especially all the
different ways that TikTok
now makes it easy to make
content, voiceovers, image,
like there's, you're also
making a very important mistake
if you're not doing it.
TikTok is based on the interest graph,
not on the social graph.
What I mean by that is
as many of you know,
TikTok puts content in front of you
based on what you're interested
in, not who you follow.
This is a very important
insight for everybody here,
as AI and algorithms continue to increase,
that is a much stickier
way of doing content
than following people.
By not making TikToks right now,
you are not getting the practice
of understanding the interest graph,
which would 100%
going to be the way the
next platform is built.
And so you're not getting
accustomed to that format
which is almost like not
running on a treadmill
before you have to run a marathon.
So another reason TikTok
is incredibly important
is it's prepping you
for the next iteration,
and by not doing it,
you're getting even further
behind as a content creator
because your brain
starts going into interest graph creation,
which is very important.
So when TikTok was first popping
and I was making content,
'cause I was making content
when it was musically
before even the TikTok acquisition,
a lot of people are
like, what are you doing?
This is for 13 year old girls dancing.
And I'm like, it's not, it is now,
but Facebook was only for college kids,
and Instagram was just for photographers.
Platforms evolve.
I think that,
yes, it's important to be
contextual to the platform,
but not at the expense
of your authenticity.
So I'd rather you deliver
the way you would deliver on
Twitter and LinkedIn on TikTok
and let the chips fall where they may,
than for you to not be who you are.
At the same token, there
is very much creative ways
to deliver serious information on TikTok.
And I think there are
countless examples of that.
And so I think that,
yes, I think you should be
contextual to a platform,
but not at the expense of the content.
- Gotcha.
- You don't have to dumb it down.
- Yeah.
- You have to make it
contextual to TikTok.
- We talk a lot about diversify revenue.
What kind of advice would
you have for the guys
in terms of diversifying
straight out of the gates right now?
- To do it.
Diversifying your income streams
is always a good strategy.
- Oh, it's not?
- Is always a good strategy.
- Always a good strategy,
yeah.
- Of course.
- Gotcha.
- Now having the capacity
or back to some of the subjects
that you just mentioned,
some individuals here
content is more conducive
to other revenue streams.
If you've got a health
and wellness platform,
it's easier for you to sell
a health and wellness product
than let's say being a doctor.
Like, but subscription
products of premium content
is always in play for people
that I think a lot of people
don't think about instantaneously.
But yeah, I mean, in creating
as many revenue streams
as possible is always a good idea,
the problem is, it's back
to content and platform.
You have to actually be decent at it.
Like if you're gonna sell a product,
the product needs to be good
or you're not gonna have repeat business
and that's not a viable business.
So I think, you know, we started with this
and I'll bring it up again with revenue,
self-awareness is very important.
You know, if you don't have any passion
for creating a product,
well, then it's probably a
bad idea to create a product.
- Hmm.
- And so I think,
but yes, I mean, I think
relying on brand deals is fine
because there's so many businesses
and there'll potentially
always be opportunities,
but the more you can control
it, the more interesting it is,
which is why I think so many creators
eventually go to their own product.
One of the things as
creators we think about is,
how do we sustain for
a long period of time
because people may get bored?
There's many different
ways to talk about this.
First of all, I once took
a two and a half year gap
of producing any content,
two and a half years.
So for five years, I did wine
content from 2006 to 2011
and then in 2014 I started
the #AskGaryVee Show.
That's a long gap.
So I think a lot of times
we beat each other up,
you beat yourself up for
not producing content.
I'm potentially one of the
most prolific content creators
of the last decade, and I
once took almost three years
where I made almost no content.
So I hope that gives
everyone a sense of relief
that if you have a bad
week or even a bad month,
it doesn't mean the end
of your content career.
That's number one.
Number two, notice what
I came back and did,
after five years of doing wine content
and not doing content for three years,
the content pillar that I
decided to do was a Q&A format.
Why did I do that?
Because I needed the audience
to be a contributor to
the content creation.
I think one of the great mistakes
that a lot of people make
is they don't incorporate their audience
as a potential starter to creative.
It is an amazing training
wheels set up, chess move,
putting you halfway home,
incorporating your audience
to being a starting point to more content
is something more people need to do.
Q&A's, answering questions, interactions.
And then finally,
I'm a very big believer
in what I do with DRock,
like filming your day to day
is an incredible way to scale content.
The other thing I did was I
did a ton of podcasts and shows
that had very small audiences
just to be on the
receiving end of questions,
so that I would have content.
So literally DMing small
podcasts and saying, hey,
if you'd like to interview me
and as you're evolving
through your career,
that's a good get for a small podcast,
so it's good for them,
but it's also good for you
'cause you can post, produce the creative,
and what's amazing about Q&A
is the questions take you to
places you won't take yourself.
So those are some things to think about.
I view that content is the oxygen
that creates awareness
around what you're doing.
So to your point, if you stop
creating to do something,
you in essence are turning off the oxygen
of what you're doing.
So the reason I have
continuously content created,
even though I've gotten
remarkably busier in my time
is because I agree with that.
I think once you stop creating,
you become less vulnerable.
Oprah Winfrey businesses
are not as impactful today
as they were a decade ago,
'cause she doesn't have a show.
That's just real life.
And so yeah, I'm a
believer that at all costs,
as a matter of fact,
one of my biggest anxiety
points professionally is that
because now VeeFriends is so successful
and taking up my time, while
I still have to run VaynerX,
the thing that, we only have
so much time in the day,
the biggest casualty
to the huge success that I
have in NFT land is my content.
I am definitely in a
different output place,
I mean, I went seven, eight years
without
(upbeat ambient music)
putting out four pieces of content
on my Instagram every day,
and now I get two a day
and that's like a big
day and that adds up.
And so I'm conscious of
that, I think about that.